and was I remember when I was there an
anti- Palestinian sentiment an
anti-muslim sentiment get the out of the
country this is Jewish country only we
don't need Muslims they weren't really
laughing they really think that they're
they're just there they're just extra it
really was Israelis are your are your
friends Israelis are the ones who will
take care of you the Palestinians are
not going to take care of you take
advantage of you you know while I was
there one interesting thing I remember
being in the Golan Heights which is um
the contested area where uh like
bordering Syria and we went on a like a
Jeep tour through it and I remember
there we saw barbed wire fencing and we
see a sign that says danger land mines
so behind there there were plenty of
Mines it was Minefield and he says you
see our tour guide you see in English
and in Hebrew it says Minefield but in
in Arabic it says picnic area wow it's
not the only time that we kept hearing
like you know oh don't trust the
Palestinian taxis they're going to rip
you off there is and was I remember when
I was there an anti- Palestinian